welcome back to GameSpot's coverage of
e3 2016 I'm sorry Missy three already
I'm feeling like it's like earlier this
morning I felt like it was there was too
much III and now I'm getting sad so I'm
delighted Graeme Jennings that you're
here to talk to us about halo wars 2 and
because I guess there are a lot of games
that were leaked ahead of time and you
guys were one of the very few in the
microsoft conference that didn't their
first of all congratulations thank you
second of all what's have been like for
the studio for seeing everyone reacts to
Halo Wars it's been great i mean we
announced the game back at Gamescom last
year just had a little cinematic to go
with that and then this week we've come
up with a better that's playable on xbox
one yeah days that started on monday and
i'm a playable code on floor so the
response has been really good because
you know we've been waiting to actually
show some gameplay and we finally got
chance this week you guys are part of
the whole what are they calling it again
is it cross over plug anywhere yeah so
basically for xbox now one of
learnerships is play anywhere so if you
buy a title on xbox one or you buy it on
Windows 10 then you get it on the other
platform yeah so for us with Halo Wars
to your progression and your saves
continue so pick up the game start on a
couple of missions you know on xbox and
then switch the pc and off you go yeah
and halo wars i guess it was a 2009 you
have 2000 km f alright so when that
first came out it was like okay this is
great somebody's making a real-time
strategy game and they are going to make
one for consoles that's going to be sort
of easy to control its gonna be you know
work without a mess and keyboard and
it's not still like part of the sort of
core idea of the sequel or you know
especially display anywhere aspect to it
are you a little bit lighter on that no
so we we love what they did with halo
wars with the first one I think it was a
really good game they really brought you
know console RTS to life with you know
controls are worked really well on the
controller obviously have pc now as well
we're partnered with Creative Assembly
in the UK who obviously an RTS
powerhouse for decades now so building
pc controls for that I think you know
super easy so it's been really good to
get you know both control systems down
and working really early on and we've
got them both playable on the floor as
well so like rice noodles are playing
them now so it's really good yeah
d-backs great are they similar audiences
the two of them because i often feel
like you know you've got your RTS fans
on pc which are an incredibly sore
I guess passionate and they tend not
they're quite insular while they tend to
at least we won't we see on gamespot
they tend to pay a lot of real time
strategy games then on drifted outside
of it whereas on the console side it
always seemed like oh we might actually
be pulling in people who play halo do
you find that they are sort of two
different audiences or zinc is
definitely you know hardcore RTS
audience on PC and think CA and their
games have a you know a large following
just on that yeah um think Halo Wars
itself still has a large phone it's
crazy the amount of people who still
actually play halo wars already really
so the men of xbox live hours today is
you know even this year is massive yeah
and it's been our most demanded game
like this is why we're doing this right
now for Halo Wars to be a little bit
knocking on our door for you know years
asking for another once and I were
finally able to bring it to them when
it's cool yeah Alex I remember we were
talking a while ago about how was it
when you were in university or something
that was like that was all that used to
happen yeah in high school we would the
boys would all get see well all my
friends we get together and we would
play we play halo wars and the boys
would play and then the girls would
watch and then when like the boys were
done like we would play I said I just
have to so it's a very fun part of my my
teenage years I have to ask I know you
said that everyone was knocking on your
door for it but did you ever think that
you'd be returning to halo wars did you
want to yeah we wanted to for sure I
think one of the key things as well with
this was how do we find the right part
not to do it you know we're gonna step
into this and do another one if we could
have you know a solid team to do it and
when we started throwing around the idea
to create assembly everyone got super
excited right I'm were like but you know
let's talk to them and see what they
could do and then we met with those guys
and they came back with a level of
passion that we had to and then you know
it was like kind of an immediate much
and it's worked really well since
fantastic to work with those guys what
sort of time frame are we looking at
here is this happened after the events
of the first game so it's set 28 years
after the first one so basically at the
end of Halo Wars one they go in a cry of
sleep 28 years later they wake up
they've suddenly been pulled towards the
arc which is an installation we saw it
in Halo 3 so everything's been brought
into current time halo timeline is right
now so halo wars 2 takes place just
after the events a halo 5 and kind of
overall payload timeline okay was that
also kind of a request of the the fans
as well it was more for us I think we
want right to you know we have
affection in the hell universe and tell
you know a multitude of different
stories yeah bringing this to Cottondale
I was just doing more tie-ins and so on
AG talk about this trailer live it
because it's it's quite an interesting
trailer because you can sort of project
yourself into either one of those
characters as like they are the
tactician 'he's what's the idea behind
the putting that trailer out there
because so when we see this two sides
obviously on the right-hand side we have
car who returns from Halo Wars one on
the left hand side we have the leader of
the banished a tree ox so this is our
new enemy in this game so kind of show a
multitude of different units for the two
characters and it kind of you know you
see the guys coming together it's really
for that trailer it's like move can
remove you know he does this i do that
just like the game you know rock paper
scissors this goes here discuss here
this goes here so that was kind of the
idea how do we bring glutton in the
trailer and then we're working with blur
to do the trailers in the cinematics in
game and we needed the a Cinemax and
halo wars one as well right we're really
renowned at the time really high-quality
cinematic so yeah those guys are back to
work with us again for Halo Wars to how
important that is that for you guys
because obviously you know looking this
from an isometric angle predominantly
you don't sort of get to tell those sort
of like little I don't know personal
stories are happening within the
battlefield how important is that for
you guys is it because the cynical
person mean will say oh that's mostly a
marketing tool because it's like oh it's
like a really fun fancy trailer look
something like the game but like a how
important is it for like actually
telling the story within the game like
giving context for all of what's
happening I don't like the top down yeah
I think you know when we talk about
camera angle it's harder to tell stuff
in terms of cutscenes and things are not
so we use a cinematic space between
machines to really you know fill the
story and build those things in and the
work that blood does is fantastic so you
know we always get really high quality
and telling stories in the Halo universe
is part of Halo games is kind of like a
key you know it's a key fundamental and
pillar of a halo game to have a great
story throughout it so it's really
important for us to use them to how
difficult has it been to sort of keep I
mean the PCR time we're just looking at
some of the bathrooms here as well this
quote there's quite a lot going on and
some of the earlier be role as well and
how difficult has it been trying to
retain the sort of I don't know ease of
use on the controller while also you
know expanding the battle set for the
for the PC crowd so the controller for
the system we're using is based on the
hill was 11 did a really good job with
that so we've added new features and
controls to it but you know the
fundamental still it's not super
different to know it
if you pick it up you'll you know it'll
feel natural when you start to play it
when we added PC controls on top of that
we've done extra thing so it feels right
on PC as well like one of the key goals
was how do you make control systems that
feel right on each platform right there
obviously separate keyboard and mouse is
completely different proposition and
controller so things are different on PC
for example you have more control groups
you know easier of 10 instead of four ya
have a clickable in many map it's you
know ease your selection of units those
kind of things so well your control a
yeah always always a favorite and what
about new species are a new races are
new because I guess you know you jump
couple years in the future obviously a
lot of the sort of the ties have changed
and the allegiances and why not as well
but does that open up other up sort of
opportunities for you to to use people
that have been introduced in later Halo
games so we have our enemy and this is a
tree ops and he leads a faction called
the banished I'm going to talk a little
bit more about this later in the year
but the banished your enemy in this and
bring your units into the game as well
there's like a bunch of new units in and
they're playable in the beta home too
hmm we're looking at some of the base
building here actually so for people who
maybe actually missed out on the first
date awards and thinking about it it has
actually been almost about seven years
or so so there will be some people who
maybe were too young as well as I what's
the moment when the gameplay like for
those people its product is how much
does base building take into account how
much is it just moving forward with your
units within the sort of linear map
really depends what you're doing so one
of our fundamental goals for this as
well was what we call RTS for everyone
so really want to make sure that we
offer a mode that everyone can access so
on the multiplayer sweet we have a mode
called blitz oh we're going to talk
about more later this year that's really
fast to action quick games new way to
play RTS of the more traditional mode
like in the Bayer that will start
tomorrow of death match that's more you
know establish your base start to choose
which units what tech tree do you want
so that's kind of bit slower you know
more strategic choices and then on the
floor we have strongholds so that's less
about resource management everything's
open you have loads of resources and
you're ready to go that's more about
building the right units straight away
and then that's more about map control
and domination so you adding in more
modes into the beta right now so we have
with the first four days of the beta or
domination so we decided to roll with to
playlist right for for mode first four
days of domination that's about map
control and we're on with fourth day
right
changes tonight you're like 1115 I know
you know but that's what when the day
changes yeah and then tomorrow we start
that much so I wanted to roll two
different modes and see how people fly
and when is it over the way that
finishes Monday 1159 good stuff just
when you're finished working here
probably is that's the good to it's
great we launched it here loads of
excitement cool sad part is I don't get
too babe I'm sorry yeah well I love when
people do that because so much of e3 is
good a lot of people going to LA and
getting to play these games and then so
much to the folks who are watching don't
get to play anything yeah when they get
to play something we need the time to
like play like the resident evil demo
and like this beta like in which I said
cliffy on and the lawbreakers beta is
going to take off as well it's like it
always it's like they get their own sort
of thing that the rest of us actually
you know that's what we don't get it
yeah you busy find some time to get on
the show floor the VA can sneak in a
couple of days in just at the end of the
weekend oh yeah that's only on xbox one
right that's own that's an xbox one for
this one we are actually gonna do
another one before launches well and
that will be on Windows 10 and xbox okay
so this one the goal with this one was
you know people use beta a lot for
different terms you know betta the like
three weeks before long right people do
say all those demo exactly so the phrase
bait has kind of been changed through
the years and consistency from beta 2
beta far away this for us is a true bail
you know we're not coming out till
februari next year this is a real slice
let's give it defines let's see how they
play you know let's see what issues they
have and what we can chew you know tune
and change so it's nice to launch
something so early so we get player and
fan feedback yeah with the ability to
change things based on that it's a
really good time for strategy games as
well like this here it is a bunch of
liars a lot of x games like space ones
obviously we know just had as a folks
internal war on as well talking about
that and where do you guys sort of feel
like you fit in into like into real-time
strategy like it's kind of more
accessible more mainstream sort of i
think we like to say we're trying to go
with the RTS for everyone where this is
the goal of doing more demos later on as
well and we'll solid base later on is to
make sure you were queer part of that
get me on that one they are closer to
launch is to show different modes to
people so we show eyes you know we have
stuff that easier to play quick to play
you want to play for 10 minutes we have
something for you want to play for an
hour or total
you know build a massive army kind of
rolling ball of death and then ya later
so we make sure we care for everyone
with that so I think we're trying to hit
you know the mainstream across the board
yeah and then we have the halo of wars
one loyalists and then we have you know
a big bunch of Halo fans as well you
just want more halo content yeah I
wonder if you'll have like a one group
of Halo Wars one players that just won't
move it be a can of strike 1.6 all over
and i'll just be like no we like the
pure version back here and we are
actually so we have two SKUs basically
we have halo wars 2 standard edition we
have halo wars 20 in addition to that
actually includes a remaster of Halo
Wars one right and all the dlc bundle
together and resume 9 us on the what
does it cross play the play play
anywhere play John and Leigh anywhere so
it's coming to Windows 10 so we are
actually bring a halo wars 10 that's
very cool so it's be and that's the
other complaint I think from Halo Wars
one is like why do you guys not do this
bc probably i'll actually fix them that
now and we're coming and bringing it
yeah i guess you can't fix everything at
all in one go what you're doing a really
good job great job thank you so much for
coming on thank you i saw Wits out early
next week february2014 xed year cool and
the bay it runs till end of monday
excellence where should people go to get
in on the better to just go to just jump
in on the xbox Xbox store download it go
to your xbox hey Cortana halo wars 2
beta I hope that you work right yeah
they should programs her to like respond
in a certain way if you're like playing
a halo game or something oh yeah she's a
good point should do that is that is an
idea okay thank you so much like Assad
Scotland words in the UEFA Cup by the
way yeah maybe something in future the
Welsh Gotti that the Welsh can get in
it's been 1998 though since we actually
qualified for us but that was also a
great fifa game it wasn't you were in it
yes the topic road to world cup and fifa
98 so you won't you'll always have that
i feel it's gonna be a long time before
one another fifa world cup game yeah
maybe maybe one you will combine yes
when brags that happens we like
Ireland's Northern Ireland Wales and
Scotland will all pile up and we'll just
form some kind of random football jacket
down thank you so much for watching the
games flat stage in case you haven't
noticed I've been doing this for five
days and I've gone a bit mental I'll be
back in just a little bit thank you so
much you're like supplying it she's
sticking around you got a bunch more
games here on the stage
I'm heading into play a critical role
for a little while but i'll be back on
later with that Greg rice with head
Lander Nathan valleywood below ukulele
and my notes here are we called Missy
unannounced Ubisoft V your title so I
can't wait to go in fact it's not Eagle
flight because i did that yesterday and
thanks so much stick around I hit that
subscribe button hit that follow button
and we'll be back in a couple of minutes